thoughts on alakin defense it's playable
it's not my cup of tea because this is
my cup of tea
soon to be a cup of air oh get profit
reminding me i almost forgot thanks for
reminding me
so the next game i'll play
with oh people can't see
but now people can see with this
i have to change the board style too
right
heck the match was worth more than my
last donation
here's some more lol oh thank you pie
hole
i feel like a small child with this
it's actually it's it's kind of
nostalgic
okay playing a non-random sub
i feel so childish what do i even play
what does dan play
he played that weird like c6 g6
right i forget let's play e4
this is gonna take some adjusting
[Music]
or dooming
it says game started that's good wait
what
you might have to like refresh i don't
know
yeah let's vip
mcnally there we go
chubby looking [ __ ]
oh let's play let's play what i played
against levy except not yeah i knew this
was coming
so i actually prepared this for levy
because i had a sense that he might
uh want to play this the queen looks so
yeah i was supposed to h3d
oh yeah the queen but the king looks sad
i already misplayed this i forgot my
prep
i was supposed to play h3 before um
knight f3
okay let's gambit oh no my pawn
[Music]
at bishop here i'll play c3 and play
positionally or maybe bishop here go for
the quick
moist critical mate
okay this is oh no my other pawn and
then my third pawn
[Music]
at least my penguin bishop will
it doesn't look like a little starve
anytime soon
hey it's choron
can i play this move
this is 3-2 so probably no dirty
flagging
so this is actually kind of a cool line
[Music]
i'm not sure if it's a good line
[Music]
okay so the the calculation is bishop c3
queen e4 queen e494 bishop
it's hard to do serious calculations on
this set
but bishop h8 f6 my bishop's about to
get trapped i have bishop
c4 preventing king f7
[Music]
uh then like bishop g8 even
can march the pawn too it's interesting
the problem is if i lose the bishop i'm
probably just losing
so the alternative is bishop d3
but then bishop g7 i'm just down the
[Music]
pawn
so the other alternative
is to take take and then
i guess we trade and
[Music]
i castle i don't know let's play this it
looks fun
i am groot
i still don't know really what that
means
what's a groot anyway okay
so f6 i was kind of expected
now king f7 might be coming so i kind of
want to play this move
just controlling a nice diagonal i can
put the bishop on e6
knight f oh knight f7 is a good move oh
but i have a cool move bishop c8 what
does this move
threatening a pawn
[Music]
uh and maybe i'll win another pawn too
[Music]
it's so weird what is this
we could draw 96 defending and attacking
and then repeat
except that's not going to happen
[Music]
okay i should probably
let's start by taking
and then take here okay so i won some
pawns
wait my other bishop might get trapped
now this rook looks
suspicious
his eyes are wide
it's a very strange position so far at
least the files are open
for the end game
yeah the pieces are expressing different
emotions
like the knights are kind of just
complacent
the bishop is
i guess full
or satisfied the king just looks kind of
depressed
the pawns look kind of like babies like
they're just
beginning to experience what the world
is like
okay so if i play this move there's
rookie seven i have to play this move
we'll probably end up casting and yeah
the rooks on the files will be nice
hopefully
i'm tying down the the horsey to
defending the pawn
whoa it's sam welcome back sam
yeah this is uh the new lyches themed
whatever set
play c3 here undermining the bishop
objectively black should be a little bit
better but it's imbalanced
oh i forgot about that move
i have to just put the king on c2
now the horsey's being annoying
to play this and then pray
restricting the horsey
if i lose i'll have to blame it on the
set right
the piece designs but if i win maybe
i'll have to keep playing until
[Music]
until i lose i always play bishop f1
so threatening this actually because in
light can't oh that's a good move
um
[Music]
for probably not a great move but
it's playable
i'm trying to be tricky
i think i'll be fortunate to draw this
ooh
[Music]
okay let's go after the h pawn
now it's it's kind of double-edged the
the bishop prevents the knight from
kind of coming back
positions really opening up now
a pawn might be lost oh okay there is 93
forking me
we both missed it
it's so much easier to miss forks
don't hurt me
okay the pawns want to be on dark
squares
i'm feeling more optimistic here
i got forked
that was a good move too
are we going to see bishop nightmates
it's kind of a real possibility
wait am i still playing for a win i
might be
wait it's not over what is this game
oh it's so interesting
[Music]
so the bishop restricts the knight and
now i have this move
i'm close to winning
walk the king in
how i win this
oh there's a cool way to maybe win
the penguin bishop is gonna just
there we go wow that was a weird game
i got forked but somehow
yeah the the penguin bishop and baby
pawns
made their way to greatness thanks for
the game
okay i was it was difficult to like kind
of
have board vision
um i definitely got outplayed there is a
missed fork
where was it
thanks for a great match last night
sorry for you that it turned out the way
it did but it was definitely
entertaining and educational i
appreciate that
reigns eight or resonate really
appreciate it
yeah i don't think i deserve to win that
it was a cool game though um
i prepared exactly this for levy i even
have
my um do i have the study
so i was preparing h3 specifically
preventing bishop g4
but i allowed it here is wonder
is this a line
oh this is a line so bishop d2
knight f6
engine likes bishop c3 i don't think
this is a good move though
it'll say plus one and then once you
play out the
few moves after f6
oh maybe it's still okay if i play like
really precisely
yeah that might that might go on youtube
it was a cool finish
so bishop c4 was a bad move apparently
i was scared of the king walking in
knight g6 was really strong though
because i've
yeah i missed this idea
and bishop c it's a funny [ __ ] way to
attack from behind i was half expecting
to repeat
um so how does h4 work
because king here
ah h5 king here i just take and then the
rook helps defend
and then weirdly it's it's hard for
black to win the
bishop oh and and i'm mating here bishop
c4 is just mate
oh wow e6 bishop e6 mate
oh some funny lines it's such an unusual
mate because usually
the bishop is not on h8
in such a way
do people like this board should i use
this more often
was my first game on the horsey board
yeah it was like an end game it was just
kind of a matter of
grinding away um
it's still tricky here because i have
these b5 ideas
wow so yeah already like blacks black's
under pressure
wait a minute oh it's not even losing
for me i thought i was losing here
i guess i have enough time to evaluate
my game and let me know what i did wrong
ooh uh if you
yeah if you uh let me know the game
thanks for the thousand bits enemy owner
appreciate that
so was there any i'm just curious
like the point of no return i guess
already here it's not so great
yeah there's a cool line um
that was calculating h2 c6
oh but 96 check
oh this wouldn't work so i'll have to
move back the bishop and then
later c6 you missed bishop c3
ah yeah well bishop c3 here i have
b5
but it's one way to just simplify
ah i see the pole so
65 percent say no to the horsey board
thanks brian for running that